mean sonic got to um we got to be
embedded with san bernardino county um
their marijuana enforcement team when
they when it went to raid yeah they went
to to raid a marijuana grow that was
operated by the chinese mafia and when
we were when we got there the the people
who were working the that girl were
chinese uh chinese nationals that were
smuggling into the southern border
undocumented and they were crying when
they got arrested these are people who
are literally working off of debt they
have no idea that's their way of paying
back to the cartel members by putting
their hours in in this marijuana grows
and but the problem is like since the
cartel knows like they are like kind of
the kingpin so like they are not
involved in the ground to ground so
anytime raids happen the people who get
arrested are these undocumented liberals
uh immigrants and this is like a whole
system like hey you come into the border
and if you're if you are already paid
into the system well and good if you're
not paid the way you put work in is by
basically infiltrating these californian
deserts and by
growing marijuana and not only that
there is like cartel turf wars between
different different cocktails because
there's mexican cottages chinese cuddles
there's armenian cuddles so it's like a
whole racket armenian and chinese down
there in mexico
no in california in california wow and
there's desert yeah we saw all trees
yeah so we were out there we um
we discovered that there's an armenian
crime organization the chinese mafia and
mexican cartels are all fighting in
southern california for these large
desert properties so when i was out in
um you know i was covering the border
early with the crisis i met i met
congressman mike garcia who represents
district district 25 in california so
for for those who don't know district 25
is the purple district meaning it could
swing democrat it could swing republican
that was the same as what's her face it
was it was the district that katie hill
had but then yeah she got caught with
her
but what happened was is that mike
garcia won in that special election by
less than 500 votes and then a year
later into him you know serving for
congress he has now this cartel issue so
when i met you know congress my car
sales like hey congressman like you're
the only representative from california
like in south texas like how come you're
out here he's like hey we have a major
mexican cartel human trafficking smoking
problem back in my district the crazy
thing is like uh my garcia's district is
where my hometown is i was like wait
back in you know like palm donald valley
like we have a cartel problem he's like
yeah you got to come see it for yourself
and that's when i called sonic i'm like
you know we need to do a full
investigation find out what's going on
so we went deep dive and went into like
the cartels the the human smuggling we
even got like a little spy drone that we
would fly over the grow ops and you know
there's just so much also layers to this
and what kind of really opened up the
floodgates was that in in california
they passed prop 64 which legalized
cannabis statewide but it downgraded um
illegal cultivation from a felony to a
misdemeanor and now the cartels kind of
opened up this this black market
business and are just dominating and
then what helps them out in l.a counties
they have a very progressive d.a george
cascone who i mean doesn't even doesn't
charge anyone at all and it's just it's
kind of creating this is all resulting
from the southern border well so so
what's up with these chinese cartels are
they like how are they getting in what
are they doing so they're essentially
the same way as the mexican mexican
cartels is their start they buy property
start up illegal grow ups and they'll
smuggle their own chinese nationals
through mexico through mexico mexico and
up and up to to california like i said i
was i was shocked we were shocked
because we were like hey these are like
mexican people like we walked in so the
sheriff was like hey uh so we got some
we have a raid coming do you want to
shadow us and we were like yeah let's do
it and we followed them and once we
pulled up to the to the grill we saw the
grow there was like huge huge huge
marijuana plants getting confiscated and
then we saw like four people like
handcuffs on sitting outside waiting to
be like put into the car and then we
just peeked in and they were like
clearly not hispanic and then we were
like what are the chinese
people doing here and they were like oh
even they are smuggled through the
mexican waters to through through the
southern border and like that's the
gateway yeah ed calderon was on the show
last week and he said it's like an open
joke around the world that anyone can
get into the u.s through the mexican
border they just go to mexico and then
they update cops i mean they're right
they're right i think when peop when
these cartels or these human smiling
groups look at the what happened with
the haitians
they it almost you know we're giving
them a better argument because all they
can say is hey you just go to the u.s
you claim you're a family unit we will
push you in a caravan they can't handle
it so they're just literally gonna
process you really quick and release you
into the united states and we even did
interviews tim with with these haitians
um outside the airport and i was like
hey you know were you tested tested for
for cover 19 before being released into
the public nope of course no yeah not
only that they were treating the whole
system as like a win like they were like
oh we did send back the single males but
we kept the families and we're like okay
uh these families though so like there's
no way to verify if they're if they're
family so yeah they'll i mean like i
said this is all resulting from an open
border it has really a lot of
consequences even for just regular
american workers this big corporations
love the open borders because it keeps
their wages down yep and i mean you just
get hit all angles so yeah me and sonic
went like i said we did a deep dive two
months into it the documentary is going
to come out um next week so we really
hope a lot of people get you know just
look at it and just kind of see the
reality on the ground of you know people
being human smuggling human trafficking
i think when people think about this
they don't think that it could happen on
american soil at the rate it is but it's
it's happening and you know and ed said
this on your show too tim is that people
think that the mexican cartels are not
here they're they're here they've been
here for years and now they're getting
more emboldened people forget about the
fact that people usually
don't empathize with the topic because
they're like oh once they're here
they're here like whatever but like once
they're here they're in our communities
like i don't know what they're doing
like some of them may be like honest
workers but at times they're working for
the cocktails and growing weed and you
know terrorizing neighborhoods and
deserts where there's like no cop
presence you know people don't
understand too uh i i did a story on the
drought in california several years ago
went to a bunch of farms
i met some some young kids who were born
in america but their parents were
illegal immigrants and they were working
on farms you know like picking dates or
something or whatever fruits they do and
stuff like that down there and they were
like oh yeah you know our parents get 14
bucks an hour and i was like that's
really interesting you know and they
were like their parents aren't
documented that's what they said and
they made 14 bucks an hour and i'm like
14 bucks an hour like why not just hire
an american it's actually really obvious
no benefits
no taxes
so if they can pay someone 14 bucks an
hour
an american would have to get paid more
because of taxes on both ends the
employment tax as well as the person's
income tax so when people say things
like well they're doing the jobs
americans wouldn't want to do i'm pretty
sure if you went to an american and said
you know 15 bucks an hour 14 bucks an
hour you know a lot of people would be
like yes please
because because right now they're the
fight for 15 in new york they've they
got it basically but this was this
around the same time around the same
time i'm hearing that illegal immigrants
undocumented immigrants are getting
14 bucks an hour to pick fruit in the
fields americans are are fighting for a
minimum wage at that level because
they're not making that much at
mcdonald's or whatever
so basically they look at it this way
you know we're going to pay 14 bucks an
hour to this person and we're going to
save 7.5 percent on employment tax we're
gonna we're gonna they're gonna save 7.5
on their end so we'd have to pay 15
bucks an hour we save a little bit
but
we're still paying comparable to what an
american would get so yeah americans
would love to have that job i when i was
in l.a i was working at a restaurant
that had a lot of illegal immigrants
working there and
they were the cool people but illegally
in the country and there was this like
building on the street that had all
these like apartments in it where they
stayed and it was like four illegal
immigrants and it was super cheap rent
and i wanted it it was super nice but
compared to my place but it so yeah
but this concept too like it would you
know years ago like even bernie sanders
would come out and said um that he
didn't support open borders because of
the how it impacted american wages so
even you know he had a you know he got
pushed by the by the progressive group
but even even he saw and i think just
you know we got to take out the politics
and just say this is an american yeah
this is an american problem that we're
seeing and right now the people who are
suffering the most and being taken
advantage of are these like legit family
units or these innocent you know people
that are living in these countries that
are getting so this dream of like hey
you just come to the us you gotta get
temporary protective status the time is
to come now the administration put that
signal i remember during that campaign
kamala harris had that that famous quote
that went viral was like you know if you
come here and illegally we're not going
to deport you that's inhumane we're
going to be the more humane organization
i mean just that little quote you just
gave the cartels
said come to the border
the whole like i said surge the border
if you want to come come
give us your weak you're sick you're
poor wasn't it the american thing back
in the day that's not the america of
today we're overloaded no you mean going
to ellis island to be prosecuted yeah
like come immigrants everyone that was a
hundred years ago we're not in that
position now to take all these new
immigrants that was a poem at an island
where immigrants were being processed
legally of course of course but i don't
even think we can handle i mean we can
barely handle legal immigration right
now this country's overloaded i think we
can only optimize i think we can handle
legal immigration the problem is how can
you handle legal immigration when we
can't track all of the illegal
immigration exactly so we're like hey we
want to allocate x amount of space to
people we've got this line of people and
everyone just rushes in you're like i
don't know where everybody went or what
our resources are anymore yeah and look
what happened with the haitians fifteen
thousand came and from chile and brazil
yeah and then they get processed and
they got released in the united states
all in under like a week just because
the haitians under that bridge was
looking bad optics for the vitamin c
they're like hey just hurry up speed it
up we don't even care if you can test
him or not just get him get him get him
out of here the thing which also bothers
me and this is like a devil's advocate
argument which is like haiti is actually
a messed up country like there's like so
many things wrong with hate especially
with the president getting murdered and
like earthquakes and stuff like that so
there may be some people with actual
asylum claims there so but when you
overload the system and you have been
doing that for like five six years
maybe those people like you know who are
supposed to get asylum in an ideal world
are like lost in the dust and guess what
there's even more coming there's already
ten thousand stuck in top of chula
mexico there's even thousands more
making their way through to colombia and
panama and it's not just the haitians
it's the venous ones that are still
coming at a record number central
americans are still coming at record
number we were literally documenting the
human smuggling last night in in roma
it and it's just like you know when i
when i speak to border patrol it's like
you know the the for them and it's kind
of a little bit obvious now looking at
the hindsight but it's like just the
removal of trump's uh you know remain in
mexico policy really just opened up the
floodgates because the thinking was for
the migrants during the trump
administration is why would i pay the
cartels and human smothering groups to
cross into the u.s illegally for the
trump administration to give me a court
order but i would have to wait in a
border town of mexico which is most
likely cartel related the risk is just
too high so when the bynum
administration came out and said it's
removing the remaining mexico policy
that literally just opened up the
floodgates didn't accord overrule that
so you gotta a court overruden said you
have to do it but we i mean for my from
my reporting we haven't seen any
evidence of those uh migrants having to
wait in mexico i mean we just saw with
the haitians if it was true those those
haitians would have had to stay in sura
they were going back and forth yeah yeah
there's no border yeah i was in the i
don't know if you guys saw the video on
twitter i was in the water while when
they were transporting supplies and i
would i asked the haitians of mexican
said hey how come you're staying here
not going over there they're like we
were only eating like one time a day
over there so it's like i'd rather be on
the mexican side wow but now the mexican
authorities went to the city it was like
a makeshift
you know haitian camp and they made
those haitians move so we're getting
reports right now that there's thousands
of haitians going to reynosa mexico
which that means the direct town across
women is mcallen texas one of the
hardest hit sections in texas is that
rgb area man you were saying earlier i
think that um haitians that had moved to
haiti
that had moved to chile yes
are were living in chile for a long time
they've been there now they come up here
and they get deported from the u.s but
they get deported to haiti essentially
what happened is all these haitians were
living in chile had already had children
ids refugee status and things like that
then when the when we made the
transition from the trump to the
administration the the care the
smugglers told him your time is now if
you want to make make a run to the
states so we had thousands of haitians
come up but they got stuck in tapachula
mexico so that's the border town in
south and south mexico the government
there actually didn't let the haitians
travel without proper documents
the only thing is is that the government
never never actually processed documents
so what happened was you had thousands
of haitians living in tapachula waiting
for something to happen like sleeping on
the streets while thousands more kept
coming so so many came on the week of
september 12th which is actually a
mexican holiday called grito the local
government gave them a three-day pass to
travel and they ended up this the human
smugglers everyone they moved them up to
uh surah kunya now cunha is one of the
few border towns that's actually not
like
controlled by a cartel smuggling group
so meaning that's why in those videos
you're able to see the haitians walk
that river back and forth bring supplies
because they didn't they didn't have to
pay if they did once they cross that one
time it's done and that's when we're
with the haitians you don't find the
wristbands at all thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you